it's time for Congress to vote on
replacing Obamacare but the nearest plan
appears to be on the brink of collapse
it still does not have enough Republican
support to pass in the house the house
will vote today on a compromise budget
the president plans to sign it but he's
not happy with concessions to Democrats
he tweeted yesterday that a good
shutdown of the government would force
the Senate to pass a better budget for
next year major Garrett is at the White
House where the president is working to
save the health care bill major good
morning good morning the White House is
scrambling and the president will meet
here today with two influential House
Republicans now opposed to the latest
version of a bill to repeal and replace
Obamacare this hastily arranged session
between the president and congressman
fred Upton of Michigan and Billy long of
Missouri will look for a way to protect
coverage for pre-existing conditions
without losing the votes of house
conservatives who've recently come on to
the bill this is what winning looks like
President Trump cut a deal with
congressional Democrats to keep the
government open and running until the
end of September he landed more defense
spending but he didn't fund the wall or
cut nearly as much as he wanted our
country needs a good shutdown in
September to fix mess the president
wrote on Twitter his way of protesting
the concessions don't think shutting
threatening a shutdown is good for
America
Democrats sounded the alarm I've been
through a couple shutdowns Office of
Management and Budget director Mick
Mulvaney was asked what a good shutdown
would look like the 2013 shutdown
reportedly cost taxpayers twenty four
billion dollars it would be one that
fixes this town so what would that one
is Rives a message back home to people
that it really was as broken as they
thought that it was when they voted for
Donald Trump on health care the
president is impatient for a win as
health care coming from details no
longer allude House Republicans but
votes still do I think it's time now
right right they know it's time the
latest CBS News count shows the revised
bill teetering on the edge yesterday
Republicans lost the vote of influential
moderate congressman fred Upton who said
the new changes to the bill would
torpedo protections for those with
pre-existing conditions we
were brought up to believe that we live
in the greatest country in the world
late-night comedian Jimmy Kimmel drew
attention to that topic during an
emotional monologue about his son who
was born with the heart defect
if your baby is going to die and it
doesn't have to it shouldn't matter how
much money you make that I think that's
something now whether you're a
Republican or Democrat or something else
we all agree on that right I mean he's
doing Kimmel's plea caught the eye of
former President Obama who tweeted
that's exactly why we fought so hard for
the ACA Gayle the fate of the Affordable
Care Act appears to hinge on whether
coverage for pre-existing conditions
will be a federal guarantee or a state
option yeah many people touched by
Jimmy's emotional plea the other night
thank you very much major